ele tinha mais é loucura
olá tudo pessoal do que quem falou dário
que seja o meu tempo com muito sono no
estado sozinho não só demostra de quidam
os nae 7 breshow seu até agora ainda não
fiquem right lançou o que eu tenho do
sul que não investigou jorginho buscarei
frontal ou paisagem sorte peguei o vosso
pipoca é visto a passar quietinha e
vamos machucar segunda noite é quando é
que isto não funciona isso não tá
funcionários e máquinas tecnologia ainda
não está a funcionar como alguém pode
estar aqui produção filho de uma [ __ ] ok
pessoal só gastamos e pela ajuda que
vocês me deram eu vou ter que fazer o
seguinte eu tenho de estar
constantemente a fechar esta [ __ ] de
cortina porque não papai você mais
rápido né
agora tem que voltar para trás e ficar
muito atento a estas portas se perceber
que alguém o tempo fechar essa porta que
a hipótese a sou eu e sim por ser alguém
aqui no canto eu vou ter que fechar a
porta y é ou não é cm x 10 e 11 41 lá em
cima tá tudo bem
quando comecei eu já esqueci os
controles destaque por entendimento não
há ninguém é só teoria que o porco não
sei se é metrô nem que exista que o
porco mas nos prédios que não os atos
que a considerada e jacinta situado no
coração estiver bem difícil é muita
coisa acontecer ao mesmo tempo aqui acho
que continha já abriu outra vez né
jabril como é que é possível o estado
muito rápido que está sempre atenta e
isto foi isto que aconteceu porque é o
senhor que foi seu o peniche
vocês viram assim a primeira coisa a
fazer é sempre fechar a cortina do paa
para lá com o conseqüente a segunda que
o seqüestro eo nec nec agora já não vou
revelar minha espera lavanchy da câmera
angeles portas
aqui não tem ninguém ele o fundo também
não está ninguém temos que ver a
continuar com o que está a fazer desde
que vai continuar rap faixa é isso o que
revolta eu não sei o que é que eu fiz
mas ocorre que em algumas usinas é o que
eu acho que chamar a atenção de deus
eu acho que é para isso que serve a
usina vai bem o que eu preciso ver o uso
de palhaço aqui foi chato faixa com isso
volta aí a ouvir um barulho aqui alguém
aqui perto alguém é não não não é
possível o último tap
vamos lá com calma agora eu não vou para
carolina que o dono porque vai chamar a
atenção a do zé kweli do secam e eu não
quero isso quero ficar tranquilo e
relaxado aqui no meu conforto se na luz
nada aqui
funada também não há nada como missão
inerente porque é sempre nestas alturas
que naquele chão ainda houve um golo de
respeito total houve qualquer coisa tu
sentir e do sentir uma presença do único
aqueles quarto era para eu acho que aqui
não aqui está tranquilo aqui está
favorável mas não sei que quero fazer
também eu acho que vai ter a esconder e
agora não vai ser eu não vai ser ele
pois não eu tinha deixado tinha fechado
a porta eu tinha de fechar a porteira
isso quando é só uma crônica ele eu
tenho que fechar a porta quando são dois
eu tenho de comer que eu nem sei se eu
conheço os dois ao mesmo tempo mas não
saíram é uma exposição é que os 28
juntinhos geninho já e vamos registar as
pessoas não estamos tão amiguinhos né
possa ir ou não eu ainda está lá fora eu
acho que lá fora eu acho que tá eu não
você está em uma armadilha
não vou ganhar nada estou aqui há muito
tempo e nada acontece
eu acho que meu problema eu preciso da
água é controlar as portas meu eu não
vou conseguir brincar com a iob aí que é
isto aí eu vi uns ovinhos o quinzinho
que nené
ok aqui está tranquilo está favorável do
juiz
eu estava muito perto e ouvindo 9
vamos vamos meu deus meu e sim mas ai
meu deus não é rápido não é no mar
walk vamos ficar com muita calma temos
que controlar as portas tudo bem com
esta tudo bem com esta vamos vírus é de
cortina
bora lá para curtir é pronto se o pt a
não há pressa tudo bem agora vamos
filhos câmeras bonita aqui o second por
seu eo zé é um costume a torcida que
nesta porta do lado é que nesta ok nada
aqui tá flec
agora eu não sei pra que você veja que
toca a buzina chamar alguém eu nem sei
quem queira eu nem faço ideia mas acho
que é um pouco né
a última faixa corte ainda não posso
esquecer da proteína eu preciso ver
horas e eu não sei melhor seguir alguém
diz horas pessoal buscam rocha alguém
liga horas o som são três da manhã o
caixão durante a manhã precisa contar
agora aguenta essa cueca aguenta é que
não deixe que estuda mesmo eu acho que o
zé pupo já não é já no dia 8
eu vou ser um dia eu vou porque o fórum
dia
agora o pessoal olha lá mas já está
curtindo essa longa primeira coisa que
tem de fazer algum barulho ali alguém
anda por aqui perto foi o cupido não
preciso de câmeras
olha aqui josé coelho tac não eu sei
porque isso é que estamos é porque a
câmara não vai por si nesta porta em
breve muito em breve vai processar ele
só precisa fechar a cortina faz chacota
e isso agora volta e vai ficar atenta
aquela porta da marca
isto aqui o que é bom é que eu consigo
aí o celular eu sei lá é sinal de ataque
meu deus meu deus a não tratar ainda não
estava ainda tudo e 2001 tronics é o seu
público e usei o que um boi não já não
sei
são quatro da manhã é 4 da foc manhã
pessoal bastante já aguenta muito bem
agora eu continuo nesta câmara o que
quer dizer que ainda não avançou mas eu
posso controlar que também esta conectar
a câmera baixa mas vejo que você gosta
não caí aqui não tem ninguém aqui o
porque ainda está ali também o que quer
dizer que eu não preciso me preocupar
por agora com as portas e voltar à
contínua através de pessoal ou cinco da
manhã é o porco não está a avançar o que
quer dizer que eu vou conseguir passar
esta noite eu acho que ficar baixo da
mesa até às três da manhã eu vou fechar
mais uma vez discutindo agora vamos
fazer é o gol por baixo foi com imensa e
vou ficar aqui até às três da manhã
eu estranho que o resultado por favor eu
não vou arriscar califórnia nené eu vou
ficar aqui embaixo porque tá tranquilo
está favorável estou confiará tranquilo
tá figurava o uso do furadão tá
tranquilo está favorável está tranquilo
está favorável e seis são seis da manhã
e 2 pessoal vamos ficar porque com isto
espero que vocês tenham gostado
finalmente conseguimos passar esta noite
e como vocês podem ver este é só um demo
e eu sei que vocês pediram série querem
ver uma série mas só existem duas noite
ainda o que quer dizer que vou ter que
esperar para que eles façam mais noite
tal mas eu acho que muito em breve vão
fazer isso e quando saírem os noivos
galo e vou continuar esta série e até a
noite site 78 o que o vento porque tudo
está perdido este jogo aéreo também foi
assunto já sabe quando e como falar em
favorito fique bem e até a próxima